phải trị kích công tức để phính lợt tờ mình điện trái trong trái gian hương, ở dưới ngàn trên.
Lướng tự chóc ra sau như bài ăn thái lần.
Cái buc, mi xanh và cái buc trị nghiệp bột các người nào vầy góc ăn thà để bằng chiếc lộ.
Trong công tức tính lợt tờ này cửa lộ sau nếu ý trở về.
Bệnh mắt của kia và đi tính cương lộ ra nha khi.
Trái chóng cái mặt ký này.
Bột số em ở thấy ở đây, bệnh ký, ký xanh biệt bộ cửa lộ hi này có phản,
Bộ bối điện cho ổ của cái thang mơ nữa
Cậu bối điện cho ổ nộ này cái trở air lợ nhỏ của guan
Đại cũng thức ạ
Cậu cứ thầy
Để số bà ngay, xuất đi ngập Air hằng ngơ nhường
Một phẩy nằm, một phẩy nằm, chiều cho ổ
B chở air lợ, là không phẩy chiến
Điện cho Air lợ
Bộ bối ngờ bằng air
Cậu bối Air lợ nhỏ bằng không phẩy nằm
Nhưng vậy là bằng một phẩy nằm
Một phẩy nằm mà chí lợ cho ổ hằng
Bằng không phẩy nằm
Để bà lại, bây giờ là không phẩy nằm, phép là không phẩy nằm
Cậu bối nằm, nhắn bối í, không phẩy nằm
Nhắn bối nhớ là bằng một
Nhắn bối xin của ngốc
Chí biểu, lực dạc bàn
Cậu bối phẩy nằm, lưng nằm, lưng nằm, lưng nằm, lưng nằm